how do i get out of here
now that the technology's been invented
it seems like we may be entering another
renaissance type period from disney with
more room to play and less time devoted
to innovating the future is bright so
we're looking at all those pesky little
elements that took movies like snow
white and turned them red but before we
dive in you should probably subscribe to
our new channel the things animated to
get all the hidden secrets and unique
theories behind your favorite animated
movies and shows
number one we're about to get all
tangled up in hair history tangled was
the beginning of a long long journey
stopping along the way in movies like
frozen and moana to get to encanto the
first animated movie to feature every
single hair type rapunzel's 70 feet of
hair couldn't ever be perfectly flat her
140 000 strands were broken into 147
groups because animating that many
individual hairs is obviously a problem
this would be the forerunner to tonic
the industry standard for designing hair
today this evolved in frozen where they
learned how to braid using the new
grouping technology they'd created
stepping away from walt disney animation
studios over to pixar they were working
with the program taz to figure out how
to give the spring-like texture to curly
hair in brave a feature that we wouldn't
see in disney until moana where they
developed an elastic rod model for the
hair to hold its curl and make it easier
for the characters to interact with they
also developed a program called
quicksilver to automatically pose hair
which harkens back to disney's
hand-drawn animation with dynamic and
flowing locks that defied the logic of
cgi programming the shading and curling
technology from moana was pushed to the
extreme for encanto where they finally
nailed doing full coils and many many
shades of hair the early days of cgi
were a step backwards in animation as it
took years to rebuild these tools that
hand-drawn movies already had access to
in their own way now they've gone to
infinity and beyond i've never even had
a bad hair day but
whatever
number two one glass bottle changed
everything cars needed complex
reflective surfaces its entire movie and
so automatic reflection was developed
this model was scrapped for monsters
university though anytime a light was
added to a scene it automatically
created the necessary reflections on
every character and object cars 3 took
the reflections further again by
creating a bump roughness technique
allowing for imperfections to reflect
light separately this all started with
one moment in a bug's life with a glass
bottle i'm sorry a magician never
reveals his secrets
number three
if they animated sully's every fur by
hand monsters inc would have come out in
2023. the invention of simulation was
revolutionary for many things including
fur in that it allowed the animators to
not have to animate every single one of
sully's three million pieces of fur by
hand the fur could respond to things
like movement wind and gravity remember
that dog in the first toy story vertec
has come a long way thanks to sully
you've been jealous of my good look
since the fourth grade pal
number four
so can you fathom how hard it is to
animate a man playing the piano like
they did with seoul the piano rig they
created was technically playing the
music all by itself gel was just
animated alongside it he had 292
controls in each of his hands far more
than miguel and coco but just look at
101 dalmatians they only had very small
snippets from behind of roger playing
the piano and now we get these gorgeous
close-ups
i was born to play number five cooking
an animation is as deceptive as
billboards for burgers food has come a
long way from ratatouille to turning red
they studied food photography for
ratatouille and developed a technology
for light passing through food inspired
by the clownfish in finding nemo the
hope was that no food would look waxy
hard or plastic turning red took cooking
to the extreme because it needed to
honor the anime style borrowing from
what was learned in bao they managed to
give us such juicy looking lettuce the
key was in perfecting the glossy texture
have you ever wanted to eat lettuce this
bad wouldn't you rather hang with dad
number six populated settings weren't
always a reality in animation
turning red created a program that can
show the diversity among all of the
other characters in a scene in one
single frame and kanto also had very
complex background characters with a
range of different skin tones and
hairstyles that pushed boundaries it's
easy to populate towns and cities with
characters now as opposed to toy story
where they tried avoiding animating
humans whenever possible the pizza
planet scene is so void of any life
forms that it's just uncanny when you
watch it back great idea woody i like
your thinking number seven the moment is
finally here hand-drawn animation is
trendy again well sort of 2d elements
were used in both soul and turning red
due to their incredibly unique animation
styles creating the great before in
seoul was an interesting challenge the
jerry's and terry's of the world
required new technology to be developed
they started with wire puppets to
reshape the characters and see what
would be possible when they transitioned
to on-screen calling it a living line
while turning red had problems animating
things like the 2d eyes of the character
while we may never see another truly 2d
animated movie from disney again we can
expect to see more of this hybrid design
in the future my panda my choice mom
number eight nemo paved the way for luca
to be more creative finding nemo was
innovated in its water techniques the
key to that beautiful underwater look
was light passing through objects the
jellyfish were a challenge they didn't
just need them to be transparent like
glass or translucent like a shower
curtain they were more distorted like
bathroom window glass depth was another
factor the further into the background
creatures and objects got the blurrier
they became just like in real life the
water evolution we got from luca was
much more stylized because they were
able to do things like graphic eq'ing on
a much larger scale for the waves which
meant they were able to change the size
of all the waves in one shot
i'm amazingly bad at swimming
number nine
where is my super suit in the first
incredibles the characters weren't even
wearing suits they were just painted
onto their actual body that explains why
they were also skin tight now coming
into the incredibles 2 they finally
created real super suits working to
preserve things like wrinkles and fabric
that moved realistically with motion
that bump roughness they created for
cars 3 came in handy for creating the
suit for elastigirl that held its
details even while stretching the detail
in elsa's dress from the first frozen
movie to its sequel was immaculate every
thread can be seen up close this was
taken further in encanto where all of
the clothes have the character's
personality patches in great detail
there's gotta be an answer something
we're not seeing
number ten
toy story had very limited movement when
it came to swiveling around but now
there's as much freedom with moving the
camera as there is in live action wall-e
changed everything the first act was
meant to feel like it was an actual
camera operator shooting it took time
for the camera to find the action of the
shot and then refocus on the characters
number 11. sequels are the ideal place
to develop wave technology frozen 2's
waves got to look so realistic that they
actually had to dial it back but before
frozen 2 came cars 2 where they'd
developed tessendorf to simulate the
dangers of choppy waters number 12 which
has more points creating smooth surfaces
came with the short in a bug's life
called jerry's game compared to toy
story it was a huge leap forward because
the skin and toy story didn't exactly
look smooth or real but a bit more like
unrefined polygon shapes the new
development was the subdivision
technique where when you divide the
lines enough times it appears smooth
number
thirteen disney was late to the party on
transitioning to cgi pixar which had
started the trend with toy story was
doing awesome at the box office
dreamworks had hits like shrek and
disney struggled to catch up remember
chicken little it's okay you don't need
to
today is a new day
number 14. congratulations you can now
animate pimples cgi movies had very
little texture at first toy story 2
added shading to it to differentiate
between the toys more plasticky skin and
the humans like in the first movie this
addition allowed them to detail the skin
with things like veins pores and sweat
number 15 finally broad shoulders the
incredibles was revolutionary for
creating layers of muscle the company
hadn't worked with characters who had
broad shoulders like mr incredible
before that's why andy's toys buzz and
woody had ball and socket joints and
stitches
number 16.
frozen 2 was different from any other
movie because the elements were
characters the crew had to figure out
how things like wind behaved which was
separate from the programmed weather
this had opened up a whole world of
possibility for the future of animation
like perhaps pixar's elemental and even
looking at the design of te fiti and
moana she was more human than element
[Music]
hey i mean have you been
number 17. do you think hank got named
hank because of the phrase hunky dory
the octopus hank from finding dory never
could have appeared in finding nemo it
was impossible at that time to create
characters without any sort of bone
structure never mind the jellyfish the
range of sea life that became possible
for finding dory was impeccable number
18 the hand-drawn animators were
cheating all along the transformation in
luca was done in full view of the
audience one scale at a time this is
very different from disney's hand-drawn
transformations like cinderella and the
little mermaid which relied on bright
glowing lights and silhouettes to
disguise the transitions
number 19 the future of animation is
virtual reality while we may not be a
long way off from a full vr movie the
live action the lion king already
capitalized on virtual reality as a tool
for creating worlds specifically the
trees they wanted this movie to feel
more like the real world rather than the
stylized animated the lion king not
every tree is perfectly arranged this
crafting in vr will prove to be one
useful tool among many in just under 100
years animation went from pencils to vr
number 20 ye old objects in toy story 4
the wear and tear on objects became
super important given the thousands of
antiques in the store borrowing from
cars 3 they further developed micro
damaging objects the program has three
levels from newish objects to extremely
worn out disney's always keeping us on
our toes do you think we will see an
animated virtual reality movie from them
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things